so today I thought we'd take a little
bit of a deeper look at Joe Biden's 2020
platform and I don't just want to read
through his positions what I want to do
is pick a few areas and think about
whether Joe Biden's ideas whether Joe
Biden's policy positions his policy
prescriptions is platform with Joe
Biden's policy ideas really deal with
root problems or would they fix symptoms
of a problem and I want to make a couple
of things clear number one we have a
system that incentivizes dealing with
symptoms and not problems when you're in
Congress you have a reelection every two
years and you have to justify being
reelected presidents have four-year
terms
senators six but of course it's much
more difficult to get big things done
sometimes in the Senate depending on
what type of thing you're talking about
although that doesn't always apply so we
fundamentally have a system that
encourages not really dealing with the
systemic problems which often take more
than two or four years to deal with but
rather dealing with symptoms or even
appearing to deal with symptoms without
actually dealing with them so we're
going to talk about that now a few
important things to think about one is
I'm going to go by Joe Biden's stated
2020 platform now there are going to be
people who write to me and say I don't
believe that Joe Biden actually wants to
do X or Y even though he claims he does
listen to some extent no president does
what they promised and every candidate
states that they will try to do things
that are very difficult to do or almost
impossible to do look at Donald Trump's
presidency for an example but this is a
pointless exercise if we're simply going
to say oh here's Joe's list of stuff he
wants to do I think he's just lying okay
I mean listen to that's it's it's
impossible to defeat that argument if
you want to insist on making it number
two some of you might say well why
aren't you talking about Biden wanting
to cut Social Security again I'm going
by Biden's 2020 platform in the 90s Joe
Biden said he would consider putting
Social Security cuts on the table if a
proposal otherwise made sense
him it was 25 years ago it's not part of
his platform today there's no real
reason to include that in his platform
because it's simply not lastly when I
talk about solving a problem versus
dealing with a symptom let's use an
example from the Trump presidency Trump
believes the solution to undocumented
immigration is to build a wall across
the entire us-mexico border
building a wall at best deals with a
symptom right the wall would potentially
slow down the portion of people coming
to the US illegally by physically
crossing the us-mexico land border
that's a symptom of the problem to solve
the actual problem you would have to
deal with number one the economic
conditions in Latin America that lead
people to want to come to the United
States illegally in the first place you
would have to deal with more strictly
punishing or punishing at all companies
that hire undocumented immigrants
because as long as companies keep doing
that and not being punished they're
going to continue doing it and number
three you would also have to account for
the higher prices that would come on
many products if indeed you rooted out
all undocumented labor in the United
States so building the wall maybe
addresses part of one symptom but it
does nothing to deal with the problem
that's the type of thinking that we want
to do here I'm not gonna do all of Joe
Biden's positions but let's do some of
the key things will start with criminal
justice on criminal justice Joe Biden
wants to eliminate mandatory minimum
sentences eliminate private prisons and
the cocaine sentencing disparity and the
cash bail system and eliminate the death
penalty so to answer whether this deals
with the problem or just symptoms you
have to understand what the problem is
I would generalize the problem with our
justice system including the courts and
criminal justice system as we have a
two-tiered system one for the rich and
one for the poor with a heavily
racialized component and a for-profit
component that has no business being
there and it is at its core a system
that is focusing too much on street
crime and not enough on corporate and
white-collar crime so when I look at
what Joe Biden wants to do on criminal
justice I would say that this is
somewhere in the middle
between fixing symptoms and dealing with
the problem Biden goes directly at some
elements of the problem so ending cash
bail and private prisons that deals with
the for-profit component of the problem
but the problem is way bigger and this
proposal from Joe Biden does nothing
about setting priorities in terms of
street crime versus corporate and
white-collar crime doesn't address that
at all
Biden also is not in favor of
legalization of cannabis that is a
massive criminal justice issue and he is
not in favor of it so I would say that
Biden on criminal justice he's just
passed dealing with only symptoms
towards getting at some of the problems
but it doesn't do nearly enough that
would by the way this is trumps a
disaster so this is not a comparison
with Trump I want to make that really
clear next let's look at the economy Joe
Biden on the economy okay what is Joe
Biden's Economic Policy Joe Biden wants
a $15 an hour minimum wage he wants paid
family in sick leave a 1.3 trillion
dollar infrastructure package rollback
the Trump tax cuts meaning raised the
top rate from 37 to 39 point six percent
extend the payroll tax to $400,000
currently that caps out at about a
hundred and thirty eight thousand raise
the corporate tax rate from 21 to 28
percent tax capital gains and dividends
as ordinary income after 1 million
dollars a year and then put a 15%
minimum tax on large companies to
prevent them from using loopholes and
deductions to end up paying zero so here
Biden starts to get at some of the
actual economic problems in this country
inequality a system designed to allow
you to pay less and less as a percentage
of what you earn as you have more and
more this applies to rich individuals
and corporations as well so Biden is
getting at some of the fundamental
problems here now what Biden doesn't
deal with in terms of problems are the
absolutely sky-high costs of living in
much of the country 15 bucks an hour
it's great but it's not a living wage in
much of the country doesn't deal with
a living wage doesn't deal with the
loopholes that are disproportionately
used by the super-rich so for example
taking the payroll tax threshold up to
four hundred thousand this year is a
hundred and thirty seven thousand seven
hundred that hits people earning between
a hundred and thirty seven K and four
hundred K but then it goes away
and we can have a debate over what's
right and what's fair and what's
economically sensible but the point is
if you're above four hundred thousand a
year in income you're unaffected by that
and the ultra-rich who are really
benefiting from a lot of the loopholes
and mechanisms that exist there earning
way more than four hundred thousand
dollars a year
another example the top tax bracket
would go back to thirty nine point six
percent under Joe Biden that's what it
was before Donald Trump okay great but
that doesn't go nearly high enough and
we need we need higher and more tax
brackets we probably need there's a
bunch of proposals but we probably need
like a forty two percent tax bracket at
a million and then we would go to a
forty eight percent okay so we need more
brackets and they need to go higher
Biden does a little bit but he's not
really dealing with it at a more core
issue which is the ultra ultra rich that
as a percentage of their total income
are actually paying lower rates but
there is some good stuff in there and
night and day compared to Trump I mean
truly night and day in short Biden's
economic policy platform is a completely
predictable uncontroversial moderately
left proposal it deals with symptoms it
gets some problems but it doesn't do
nearly enough it's way better than Trump
let's do one more area for today which
is health care this is obviously huge
Biden on health care he has said that he
supports lowering the Medicare age from
65 to 60 would create a public option
would give free access to the public
option if you're in a state that didn't
do the Medicaid expansion that was part
of Obamacare there are Republican
governors who said okay Obamacare
includes this Medicaid expansion but
we're not going to do it if you are in
one of those states you would get free
acts
to the public option even if your state
didn't do the expansion based on income
up to 138 percent of the federal poverty
level that's like five million people
and then Biden would also increase tax
credits by eliminating the four hundred
percent poverty level cap and limiting
the total out-of-pocket cost to eight
point five percent of income that would
be down from close to ten percent and
the credits would be based on gold plans
rather than I don't remember if it's
bronze or silver currently that raises
the amount of the credits and then Biden
with limit launch prices and price
increases on drugs as well as allow
foreign drug purchases so there's a lot
there it is not Medicare for all it is
not Universal there's no doubt about it
what are the numbers that that this
would achieve if you lower the Medicare
age from 65 to 60 I believe it adds 18
million people to Medicare i I don't
have that number in front of me and I
had a little trouble finding it but
going from memory I believe it's about
18 or 20 million more people that would
get Medicare by lowering the age from 65
to 60 it's not universal but you know a
lot of people a free public option in
states without Medicaid expansion would
add again about five million four point
nine million people and then there are
certainly millions more that would be
able to afford health insurance with
this is it a panacea of course not of
course not is it better than Trump's
proposal with Republicans which would
have seen 24 to 32 million more people
lose insurance of course it's better
than that the symptoms are care is too
expensive it's sometimes low-quality and
it's not accessible to everyone in large
part because of the for-profit system
that we have this biden's plan changed
the problem of health care being for
profit of course not he doesn't believe
that's the problem that's a major
disagreement right now
even within the Democratic Party Biden
deals substantively with symptoms and
the way he does it is you get care to
more people and you make it affordable
for more people
but not everyone so let's step back a
little bit to sum up we have a system
that in
courage is at a fundamental level
because of the frequency of Elections
how politics is financed needing to
raise money etc and how long things take
to get done we have a system that
incentivizes appearing to deal with
symptoms sometimes you're actually
dealing with a symptom sometimes you're
only appearing to and optics very much
are the only thing that actually matters
when Congress is up for re-election
every two years when presidents get
four-year terms we have to understand
the difficulty in a system like that of
dealing with problems this doesn't
excuse candidates or presidents who
don't do it and it doesn't encourage
only dealing with symptoms we just have
to understand that reality Trump by and
large has identified the wrong symptoms
and is dealing with them in a completely
farcical way that that's how I would sum
it up Joe Biden would actually deal with
these symptoms in a way that would
function reasonably well but would only
start to get at the underlying problems
that's my assessment on healthcare
economy and criminal justice we could
look at environment and others and maybe
we will do so let me know what you think
about this framework of symptoms versus
problems I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
we'll take a quick break and so much on
today's program there's a YouTube
channel called up flip that we're
partnering with I would love for you to
check it out I've put the link right
underneath the video make sure to
subscribe to the channel when you're
there up flip is a channel that is all
about exploring small business and what
makes a small business successful every
episode interviews an entrepreneur you
take a tour of the business and these
are not generic interviews you actually
get a really fascinating deep dive into
the history of the business the mistakes
the entrepreneur made what they learned
what motivates them what a day is like
running their business and you get all
sorts of super interesting and valuable
insight about what it's like to run that
type of small business as a business
owner myself I find up flips videos to
be endlessly intriguing even if you
don't own your own business it is really
great for a general audience it's stuff
that I think just about
would find fascinating and you can check
it out by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is right
underneath this video when you're there
make sure to subscribe and click the
bell for notifications